[Music]
hello there thank you for coming and
it's really a treat for you to spend
time with me during your reunion
and i hope you're enjoying yourselves as
much as possible and we were just
discussing snow
in other parts of the country so if
you're not from california also there's
a weather treat so hopefully the weather
will hold out for you the whole time
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
myths and the rituals of inclusion
and to kick us off i want to so how many
of you have been on like a zoom or a
team's call sometime in the past two
years
okay
so i want you to pose
about how you are in your seat before
the meeting starts
okay
now imagine the zoom
or team starts
show me what you do anyone do that
right
now why is it that we have expectations
about how we are in our home
and then how we are the minute that
camera comes on
that's what i want to talk about there
are myths there are common beliefs we
have about what work is
and those beliefs are myths shape
how we behave
and when an examined can actually be a
deterrent to
creating a truly inclusive workplace
where people can thrive so i'm going to
talk about that today and then i'm going
to go into a little bit about what gsb
is doing about diversity equity
inclusion here
so the definition of myth interestingly
found this in the dictionary
is a widely held
but false belief
i knew myths were something to debunk
but when i looked it up in the
dictionary there it is something that is
false but wildly held as true
and so when we look at the workplace
interestingly
many of our myths or expectations are
widely held
but when we look at the data underneath
them they're actually false
one of them is who is a good worker
and what does good work look like
we have widely held beliefs in fact i
speak to a lot of hiring managers how do
you know the right candidate oh i can
tell
there's something about the way they
answer questions
again what is that
so one of the things we know from
research is that the ideal worker norm
shapes
who we think is the best employee
so the ideal worker norm was developed
really when there became a separation of
work and life during industrialization
before that there really was no
separation of work and life that
construct came with industrialization so
if you think about i don't know about
you but i grew up reading books like
little house in the prairie anyone read
that to your kids or grow up reading
those and if you recall the people who
owned the stores
the kids
nellie olsen
would be playing in the store
because there was no work in life it was
integrated or the farm
everyone contributed to the success of
the farm even the little kids so this
idea that there's work and life is an
idea that came through industrialization
and then to make sense of it we came up
with expectations about what it was to
be a good and productive worker because
we had never had
office or factory workers before
and the definition started to be
that when you're at work you focus
entirely on your job
and home is something that somebody else
takes care of and a lot of the laws
reinforce this divide and this idea that
anyone who's distracted from work is not
a good and productive worker now an
examined these norms start to have
things like what we might call a
motherhood penalty
so research shows that if you have a gap
or you indicate you're an officer in a
parent-teacher organization
your resume is less likely to get called
in
not because you're not the perfect
employee but because this myth about who
a good and productive employee is
pervades today and affects how we see
talent in our in our workplaces
now one myth i want us to work on today
is this idea of a meritocracy
many of our workplaces are designed
around striving to be a meritocracy
so the idea of a meritocracy is that
everyone is evaluated for the merit that
they bring to the
company the project to the team
and that every idea
is truly evaluated based on the merit of
that idea
we hold that belief widely
but research shows there's a lot of
errors that we make that prevent us from
truly seeing talent and ideas equally
depending on
the composition of the person the
identity of the person who's presenting
the idea
so meritocracy is a belief it's a myth
that all people and all ideas are
evaluated based on merit
now here's a really interesting finding
emilio castillo and stephen bernard
emilio got his phd here at stanford
they did a research on a company about a
5 000 person company
and they
went to the leaders and said what would
you like to accomplish and they said we
want to deliver on this promise of
meritocracy
we believe a meritocracy is when we very
carefully evaluate performance and then
when we give out salary increases the
performance
correlates to the salary increase
so they worked with this organization
had them do that they were very proud by
the end they felt that they had truly
correlated
performance
and pay increases
and then the second phase was the
assignment of a merit bonus and as you
know merit bonus is a one-time bonus
that's given based on your performance
so they asked the managers to hand out
merit bonuses
and then they evaluated them the
researchers did based on gender and race
and what they discovered was that the
merit bonus was not linked to
performance rating
but gender and race was more predictive
of how much you got and what they
discovered is that if we believe in this
myth of meritocracy
we are less likely to scrutinize our
behaviors so when managers work for what
they believe are a meritocratic
organization
they believe that they are the ones who
are meritocratic and what happens is
they stop scrutinizing their behavior
so if all of us have what we call
cognitive biases where we make errors
based on stereotypes about types of
people
if we all do that and we stop
scrutinizing because of the myth of
meritocracy
research shows that we are likely to be
more biased
than if we have concerns that were not
good and check our behaviors
so how do you debunk
this idea of
meritocracy one is there's a lot of
research that shows how these errors
take place this one i really like it's
in the field of the legal scholars
and they wanted to convince lawyers that
that bias existed even in the legal
field
and the lawyers said well no our job is
to find the truth
we're really good at looking through
something and finding the truth there
aren't biases in the legal field so what
the researcher did was created a legal
brief and put errors in it spelling
theoretical grammatical errors
sent it to law partners with the request
to evaluate their third year law student
and in it they simply wrote in the cover
letter for some
that he is white and some that he's
african-american
and i any lawyers in the house you don't
have to admit it
i've spoken to lawyers and they say
who writes a brief doesn't matter
a brief is a brief it stands on its own
merit yet what they discovered is that
when the lawyers thought that thomas
meyer was african-american
they found those mistakes that the
researchers had put in the legal brief
now notice that they didn't find them
regularly when they thought he was white
now why would that be
the historical archetype of success
affects how we evaluate things
in the past there haven't been a lot of
black legal
partners so despite the fact that for
example michelle obama is a very
well-known black legal partner
that hasn't affected our stereotypes or
how we see success
so whoever doesn't match who we expect
to be there just gets more scrutiny and
not only more scrutiny
but then he black thomas meyer got a
rating of 3.2
and we can't even believe he went to nyu
and white thomas meyer has potential
got a 4.1 and this is where the myth of
meritocracy starts to fall apart we do
these studies in countries all over
right europe asia where they change one
thing in a resume and they send it to
actual hiring managers and they see how
actual hiring managers respond so we
just talked about how race can affect
evaluations in the uk what they did was
in some resumes said that the person had
been a member of a break a gay pride
organization while in college that one
had to send in more resumes to get
call-ins
the second one in germany you can put a
picture with your cv
the exact same picture
sometimes they'd have a german name
sometimes a turkish name and sometimes
turkish with a head scarf and that was
the least likely to get called in so you
could say ethnic national origin or
religious
and then the last one was the motherhood
penalty i referred to so when a resume
says
a person was officer and a parent
teacher association it's called unless
that resume is called in less
not only that but the candidate is rated
less qualified
less loyal and offered a lower salary
now they did the same with two men's
resumes they put officer of a parent
teacher association at the bottom of a
men's resume it was called in more often
rated higher more competent and more
loyal so they call this the motherhood
penalty and the breadwinner bonus
now
i'm going to see how we're going to do
with our own automatic associations and
if you wouldn't mind calling out
picture genius
and then
who's willing
to tell me the name of a genius
anybody
please
maradona
oh
the same
emmanuel miranda
lin-manuel miranda
anyone else
einstein
the einstein
cleanse tower has the highest iq
and
so somebody who has the highest iq would
be a genius
so we have artistic geniuses we have
mathematical geniuses we have scientific
geniuses
in general we tend to pick men as genius
in general right in general when i do
this p people in general say einstein
which you threw me a bone thank you very
much appreciate it
um and what's hidden from you are often
people
women people of color who are equally
qualified in the exact same field are
hidden from view so what happens in our
brains is that when historical
archetypes are in words like genius it
narrows our view
and we end up only seeing
who matches that historical archetype
and even though there are a lot of other
folks there we tend not to notice them
if you saw when forbes launched its very
first 100 most innovative leaders in
america list
there was a big twitter storm because
the list had 99 men and one woman
now when forbes responded to this list
they said well we did use a methodology
but clearly it was flawed
so if you're not seeking to catch
whether your methodology
has these errors in it likely you are
enacting it and that's how we try to
debunk these myths of the workplace by
showing that these commonly held beliefs
are false but widely held and we can
debunk them with some of the data that
research like that is done here at the
business school is being conducted
now in this study which was in 2019 they
worked with a group of scientists and
they had them take that test to see if
they had bias against women in science
and they discovered that pretty
universally just like in the world
people have bias that men are more
likely to be scientists than women
that's not what differentiated them what
differentiated the group was when they
asked why do you think there are so few
women in science
and the ones that said i don't know
science isn't sexist we're empirical
we're put in one group
another group said i don't know either
but i know barriers exist
and then they left him alone
and two years later went and looked at
who they hired
and it turns out the group that
acknowledged that barriers existed ended
up hiring more women
and the ones that said
i don't know science isn't sexist we're
empirical ended up not hiding women
so whether you believe these myths or
not whether you seek to debunk them can
affect your behaviors in ways that
reinforce the myths or can debunk them
and come up with different outcomes
so when i think about the difference
it's not intention
scientists in both
of those groups had biases
and most in most cases people want to
pick the best person
very few people i talked to say i hope i
picked the second best candidate right
but the difference are the actions we
take to block these dynamics these myths
from affecting
our decision making and that's where i
get to rituals
so again i looked up the definition of
ritual it's an act or series of acts
regularly repeated
so that's the thing about myths if we do
something once it doesn't make the myth
go away
we have to regularly repeat actions that
block the myths from affecting our
decision making to have any sort of
different outcome and in a way i think
about about honoring who people are i
think about it as a ritual which seems
very much like a process
is actually trying to honor the person
i'm trying to evaluate really trying to
see who they are beyond these automatic
responses
so one way to debunk this myth of the
ideal worker
so remember the ideal worker is the myth
that people who have work and focus on
work at work are more productive than
those who have home concerns
one way to debunk the myth of the ideal
worker is by having regular check-ins at
work
some really interesting work done by
leslie perlow at the harvard business
school she was studying the boston
consulting group
and they were having issues because
people were feeling like they had no
control over their lives and therefore
this work life
integration was failing
so they instituted what they called
one day off predictably a week
now if you're on a consulting project it
meant even if you're in a different
state
you were off the project for one evening
a week
it meant if you were
buying tickets to a show or you're
trying to see your kids
game that you knew that night off was
truly that night off
well the teams end up being more
productive
not because that one night off was
necessarily rejuvenative although it was
it increased retention
but interestingly because they had to
coordinate across how their personal
lives worked
they ended up communicating even more
strongly about their projects
so some people argue we don't have time
for personal check-ins we're about work
work is work and personal life is
personal
but there's the chance that when you
integrate them through a simple check-in
at the beginning of the meeting you can
increase both work and personal
satisfaction by doing that regularly it
can change the tone of work over time as
prolo saw in the boston consulting group
ritual can also be as simple as agreeing
to criteria before you make a decision
if you remember that brief where the
evaluation of it shifted based
unconsciously on the stereotype of the
person evaluating it well research shows
that we will shift the criteria
so if we recall it was the exact same
legal brief
but the criteria shifted in the
valuation
it turns out if you simply think
carefully about how you're going to
evaluate someone before you do you're
less likely to shift it
so for example in the legal brief if
someone had said
did you scrutinize
for spelling mistakes equally in both
briefs
likely the ones who
looked at the one from white thomas
meyer didn't check that very well
sadly this happened to me once at work
where
and we had candidates and all of a
sudden the top candidate someone said oh
there are a lot of spelling mistakes in
their cover letter we didn't really
notice it but i think someone who's
going to be in our role
really needs to write well for the
public audience we really can't have
spelling mistakes
and so we thought oh we should probably
discount that candidate
what i didn't do and i will regret
forever is that i didn't say did you
equally check for spelling mistakes in
all the candidates
because if we had i'm sure we would have
found a similar number
because we didn't we ended up saying
this okay we took the person off the
qualified list
so simply is saying if you're going to
hold someone accountable for the way
they're communicating or the way they're
writing did you really check to see that
that was equally scrutinized on every
applicant
now
has anyone made a new year's resolution
that didn't stick
kind of thing yeah
and in fact a lot of people make new
year's resolutions around eating like i
don't know about you but do you notice
i'm wearing this little top that's
looser on the bottom than it is up here
this is what i call covet clothing
right you got the nice snug part where
it doesn't count and then a nice loose
part where the coved effect has taken
place
so lots of people have given me advice
about what to do about coveted
clothing
and
interestingly a lot of the things you're
supposed to not do
make me want to do it more have you ever
tried that like i'm only going to drink
wine you know on the weekends and then
have a really tough meeting like oh
tonight i just have one class right so
there's ways that telling me not to do
something makes me want to do it more
so it turns out in behavioral economics
there's this idea of a nudge
and nudge doesn't tell you not to do
something
but a nudge encourages you to do the
right thing
it constrains your choices so you end up
doing the right thing without having to
remember to now a good example is anyone
not from the united states here
are you shocked about how big our
servings are
it's like you could feed a family
off of one plate of food like
seriously i went to this one meal and i
can't believe i was eating it all and in
reflection it was the amount of food
that we usually buy from my family of
four but i ended up eating it because it
was on this really beautiful plate and
we were there
so it turns out
the plate size in the united states has
increased over time similarly to a lot
of the ways that we've started to eat
more
so
if you simply eat off a smaller plate
it's not telling me lori don't eat more
it's just saying like how much fits on
this little plate
so one way to help people with good
behaviors not to tell them don't eat
more it's really to figure out you know
you've heard it smaller plates healthy
sizes eat slowly all those things okay
so it turns out if you in your work are
making decisions about people without
some sort of scorecard
likely you are
making these shifts
even if your company
has
some sort of performance evaluation or
hiring platform if you as a leader
require that everyone do
and input
their evaluations into a scorecard
you're going to get less of these shifts
in evaluation
if you in your agendas just regularly
put that check in at first it will be
awkward but over time you'll get more
accustomed to integrating work and life
and have less of a barrier even during
covet a lot of women told me there was
understanding about them having kids
kind of running through their zoom
screen
and yet when we ask about promotions and
opportunities and how they feel their
advancement is going they still feel
like it was a constraint
one thing a checking can do is help
reduce that
myth
that people with things going on outside
of work are less productive than those
who focus solely on work
and then i love this idea of changing
the default
so it turns out that unbeknownst to us
we have defaults about
the way
life works if you think about for
example
parental leave
often it's structured around biological
parents
which
in some organizations they have to
rewrite it to include for example
adoptive parents or
step parents right so the default is a
biological parent
by shifting that it creates more
inclusion
organizations
well the way we talk also has a lot of
defaults
so if you say for example
i want to welcome all the couples and
the same-sex couples
what i'm saying is the default
is a one-man one-woman couple
and everyone else is an exception
so our words have ways of again
indicating who is more included in our
organizations and who is an exception
and if you've noticed around stanford a
lot of us will put our pronouns
on our zoom
ids or when
we work with undergrads it's often
incorporated into how they introduce
each other
now why is it important that everyone
shares their pronoun
well it shifts the default
the myth is that there's a default
and everyone else is the exception
but by shifting the default we're
debunking that myth
so by sharing my pronoun my name is
laurie mackenzie i use she her pronouns
i'm saying the default is that we all
might have different pronouns than you
expect and therefore it's it's just the
way it is that we share them
so in your workplaces as well there may
be defaults that are unconsciously being
reinforced
where there's something without
right a descriptor and everyone else
gets a descriptor and the question is
could you catch those and make it so
that everyone is included not a default
and an exception
okay
now what have we done here at the
business school around some of these
myths and some of the ways to create a
more inclusive campus
and if you didn't know we've been
publishing a diversity equity inclusion
report for the past few years this is
our third report which just came out
and in all honesty we keep shifting when
we publish it so it's not like you would
know it comes out a certain time of year
we rely on central stanford data about
our representation and we are kind of
working out when that comes in and then
when we write our report but i wanted to
share a little bit with you about how
we've tried to be more inclusive in the
work we do
so one of the myths that we as a
university as people need to debunk is
that well everyone can be their
authentic self
and there's lots of data that shows
that's not true equally for everybody
so one thing stanford university did was
they conducted the largest scale culture
survey ever in our history
president tessier levine launched it
after the murder of george floyd and
said he wanted us to understand how race
affected how people felt here at
stanford
14 almost 15 000 people answered this
survey it's the very first survey we've
ever conducted across students staff and
faculty
exact same survey because what we wanted
to understand was how is it that people
are experiencing the culture
is that myth true that everybody can
equally be their authentic self
this survey you can find it online
they've put all the results to be
available because transparency also
helps debug myths giving everyone access
to data
what they discovered was that race and
sexual orientation sexual identity play
a huge role in how people feel that they
belong here on campus
so what have we done about that
we pilot what we call a small winds
approach to change it's hard to change
the whole culture so we take bits of it
and we try to evolve it in some of the
ways that i talked about today
so one of the things we did was last
year we said we want all of our
resources
developing new cases
to focus on leaders
of color
and it went from just one percent of our
cases being to adding 35 new cases last
year
and i heard one of the students share in
a course saying
this was the first time
when i was in my class and there was a
protagonist of color talking about their
startup
not talking solely about being a
protagonist of color or like an
entrepreneur of color
but being one and sharing about their
amazing startup
so it really can go a long way in having
our students
feel like yes they truly can
thrive
regardless of
how they look or where they come from
we've also
thought about how we can help our
faculty
create more inclusive classroom
experiences and this just ended the
student panel was just this week so we
did a couple of things first two years
ago we launched a
training called sensitive topics in the
classroom where we talked about how to
manage sensitive topics
that come up through current events or
case studies that could
inadvertently are comment that could
inadvertently cause someone to feel like
they didn't belong
and then this year what they did was we
went a step further first we had a panel
and invited faculty to attend of three
faculty who shared their experiences of
both creating an inclusive classroom but
also dealing with pushback against their
identities in the classroom and what
they did
and then just this week will torres who
works in our admissions curated a panel
of force five students
who shared their experiences in the
classroom when it wasn't inclusive or
shared how amazing it is when professors
did certain things to have their
identities be welcome in the classroom
so again how do we as a as a business
school as a leading business school
create environments where everyone can
equally see that they thrive
we had a conversation with staff on
thursday
with brian cook who works in our
institutional research
and ayadeli thomas who is the head for
staff diversity equity inclusion for all
of stanford where we wanted to tell them
we're going to share these survey
results with you and go through them
with you so everyone understands we're
not hiding the data
we're sharing the data so that we can
all think about ways that we can
reduce the barriers for people feeling
like they belong
and lastly we've been looking at the
curriculum we do i don't know if has
anyone been to building momentum
so it was originally designed for women
alums entrepreneurs to help them succeed
in the ecosystem of entrepreneurship
and then in 2021 pivoted it thinking
well we're online
why don't we take advantage of that
instead of being just for women the idea
was to advance diversity
and to give access to the amazing
curriculum offered here at the business
school to anyone who is able to log on
and as you can see there were 355 people
who attended and there were requirements
for registering it wasn't just if you
were interested in hearing
and 62 of them ended up being
non-alums which was really great for us
to share our good work and 50 of of our
attendees were either black or latino
us-based attendees right
so thinking about our curriculum our
classroom experience our staff
trying to debunk the myths that it's
fine the way it is and figuring out how
we can be proactive and creating more
inclusion and
more to be proud of here at the business
school
if you haven't read it
it's on our website it's it's um
if you just look for diversity equity
inclusion report we have six priorities
that we work on here and we've been
working on for the past three years
one to increase the diversity of our
stanford community two to create an
inclusive classroom and learning
experience
to create an inclusive and welcome main
campus community
support new research efforts especially
around diversity equity inclusion
share our good ideas with the world as
with the
conference i shared about
and then we've integrated our action
plan for racial equity into the core
report with the last priority which is
to address racial inequality
in our community and society
so while we still have a lot of work
left to go
we're going to keep trying to debunk
these myths and install nudges and
rituals so that we can
not only for ourselves the student
experience but hopefully
as that
saying goes you know change lives change
the world change organizations change
the world hopefully by debunking the
myths we will
create more opportunities to for people
to truly achieve their fullest potential
[Music]
you